per tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a me
solo episodio di non so pilotare nero
quindi mi schianto per terra simulator
allora ragazzi previsioni è piaciuto
tantissimo e sono contento sono
veramente contento perché è un gioco che
mi fa impazzire anche a me quindi come
abbiamo visto ragazzi la cosa bella di
questo gioco che puoi andare ovunque nel
mondo ovunque dove cacchio anche a casa
tua
questo ci permette di fare di
videopazzeschi ad esempio la prima cosa
che mi viene in mente di fare è provare
ad andare nell'area 51 direttamente con
file sicurezza ragazzi faccio una
premessa gelosissima siccome l'area 51 è
un grosso precisamente vietato non ci si
può andare lo sapete tutti
non sono sicuro che ci sia perché cv
visto che il gioco riproduce il mondo ci
sono di alcuni enti lo so perché ho
detto che hanno chiesto alla microsoft
di essere tolti quindi credo potrebbe
anche essere che non ci sia niente però
allora siamo ad indian springs
l'aeroporto va verso ovest e noi
dobbiamo andare assolutamente a nord
quindi quella direzione
ho capito un bel po più di cose
dall'ultimo episodio di soho guidare si
regola per l'area 51 o bellissimo non
vedevo la ripa sta roba
vado alla velocità del solo troppo bassa
la chicca sempre io devo lo quando mi
parlò allora c'è la fina 76 nodi per
decollare
mammamia effettivamente o denilson
decollato un pelo prima allora viviamo
già subito carrello d'atterraggio viali
per tensionatori tu madre perfetto in
flux molto bene molto bene signori ci
siamo allora la direzione è proprio
quella ce ne vuole secondo me perché in
america sembra tutto vicino ma le robe
sono abbastanza distanti e io ci vado lo
stesso faremo lì ci raccontiamo della
nostra vita che una volta i tagli a
gianpi ok ok scherzavo e facciamo su
questo perché è veramente con le prima
andava come mi nonna
ragazzi vi ai freni correre la manetta e
andiamo tutti a mignano non era tanto
per arrivare solare 51 il fatto è che
poi vorrei andare appunto las vegas e
con quello facevamo notte quindi
è veramente ognuno anche perché di notte
cervello perfetto ma incolla sì ma dove
possiamo decollare 120 noli parte coda
con questa dai va bene ma ho fatto
analista allora il getto ancora prima di
decollare molto bene fa niente raga vi
confermo che esiste l'area 51 ce l'hanno
fatta pazzesca sta roba raga sono
riusciti a parlare a 51 moore e cioè
farla non è gran parte hanno preso le
mappe
però vorrei proprio vedere non credo
allora a questo punto non penso sia
dettagliata
perché se fosse dettagliata sarebbe
veramente strano perché lavorando tenuta
piatta immagino quindi come se quasi
come se non ci fosse che sennò non
costiero comunque sto impazzendo raga
veramente figo allora diminuisco
diminuisco parecchio
vediamo che cacchio cia perché comunque
sono con un jet era tener conto anche di
questo io tento di diminuire parecchio
la velocità in modo tale da rimanere a
velocità più bassa da anche perché siamo
con il jazz
purtroppo come è cambiato il nome o cosa
che si chiama o mail all area 51
abbiamo forse poteva decollare
addirittura da qualche mi fa troppo
strano però avere
minuti molto bravo no come le rose
schiattato la cosa è vero perché nostro
senatore eccessivamente perché dovevo
scendere veloce di portarci mi avrebbe
abbiamo visto che c'è e decolliamo dalla
direttamente allora ragazzi
effettivamente questa è l'area 51 l'ho
presa direttamente dal decollo con
l'aero non è ovviamente di un potente
retta ma si vedono i bunker 6 voi cari
ragazzi chiama i capannoni dove tengono
dovete qui dove tengono enti sono questi
qua quindi è comunque una [ __ ] c'è un
autobus santo iddio ce roba strana
parecchio strano ragazzi ovviamente non
è strade tagliata perché secondo me non
potranno fare chissà che cosa visto che
il gioco li produce davvero il mondo le
rocce roba che è incredibile comunque
sia veramente strano se tu voli sopra
questa roba qua viene abbattuto di tempo
zero quindi effettivamente noi non lo
siamo certi che comanda un autobus va
bene questa ragazzi all'area51 rifarà
strano ma è così
effettivamente questa qua e l'area 51 si
può polare il salary 51 anche inflazione
effettivamente è un po strano perché mi
chiedo dove vengano effettivamente gli
alieni sono me c'è un bunker nascosto da
qualche parte tutto questo alla fine è
una copertura anche la gente provate a
raleigh faccia la gente poi dopo do
parliamo di trenta las vegas che ce ne
sbattiamo però per adesso non è male ma
netta tolta vedo se scala linee armi
anche se effettivamente un po strano giu
il carrello i flap sequestrate raggio
veramente di estrema emergenza perfetto
frena già frena lo zio frena c'è un
autobus
oddio ci è data ragione veramente strano
ragazzi ciao buongiorno sono quello con
l'autobus che ha sbagliato autobus o dio
dio e che cos'è c'è un coso lì togliti
madonna cosa ho schivato solo un
fenomeno
ragazzi ciao ma cosa ho schivato
incredibile ma dopo questo mi devono
dare il brevetto veramente signori
questa è l'area 51 ci sono pure
alternato dentro tanto io cioè il
permesso chissenefrega hanno fatto le
porte le forze di qualsiasi posto cioè
incredibile comunque ripeto secondo me
secondo me non è dettagliata proprio
perché non possono farlo avevano va bene
dire che ci siamo
possiamo arrivarci dalle balle e stato
divertente andiamo a las vegas chiantia
voci su sto palazzo chiama las vegas
perfetto allora ragazzi siamo
direttamente sulla meravigliosa las
vegas di atlete col mio aereo fake
dovrebbe essere la sveglia ma perché
tutto ragazzata sono andato a napoli
diminuiamo la lancia inler stop perfetto
vediamo se riesco a sorvolare un po
questa meravigliosa città l'ho già fatto
anche sui new york
poi magari facendo anche new york perché
è giusto per darci un'occhiata non è
male per la madonna cosa ho visto questo
è il mandala iberici hanno fatto perché
fin quando sbaglio alla piramide mi
sembra di giocare gt alla fine perché
hanno riprodotto anche questo madonna
che figata assurda la [ __ ] vegas è
proprio questa vorrei avere questa ero
nella vena nella realtà per fare questo
ovviamente non potrei andare inter messo
gli vale 9 legge ma sarebbe
divertentissimo veramente tanto c'è la
tour eiffel sciatore che la sveglia va
bene c'è una torre eiffel a las vegas
non fate domande non lo sapevo neanche
io
scusatemi e non mi intendo di
cosa succederà penso che sia il fatto
che l'engine ok stiamo precipitando che
possiamo moriamo a las vegas
sto morendo alla se c'è un palazzo non
atterrare sulla comunque sasso suncheon
marchigiane wagon a new ragazzi c'è
allora questo è pro qua siamo
all'apoteosi del secolo
adesso ragazzi vorrei fare un giro
direttamente prendendo la statua della
libertà andando dietro età a new york
con perché voglio incontrare sun già
marchigiano che dovrebbe essere nei
paraggi a lei ragazzi questa è la
meravigliosa central park orrei farvi
vedere il moma o robe del genere però
non sono così tanto esperto di new york
proviamo a vedere se riesco ad atterrare
in autostrada alla perdita non in mostra
nelle autostrade
però non mi dicono mischia ma la strada
che passa sotto l'umpire però atterrare
atterraggio di emergenza a new york
vediamo se riesco ragazzi potrebbe
essere interessante non ce la farò mai
ragazzi non ce la farò mai regole nel
bayern e le bayern occhio oddio che pero
addio manetta giu manetta giu salto gesù
la gara di addio
oddio oddio fermi ma renderizzato un
cazzo però fa niente mi sono schierato
contro una macchina
ce l'avevo fatta signori questa è la
decisione di oggi di vice simulator ce
n'è ancora io veramente fine da farvi
vedere il male il prossimo episodio
prossima settimana per avere sia
piaciuto ragazzi cosa c è bisogno del
momento è un mi piace anche vari social
che con il potente schizzare i temi e
non ci vediamo come sempre al prossimo
video ragazzi
[Musica]